[Musique]
gros soir nos amis et bien nous voilà
prêts nous avons de nouveau fait nos
bagages car nous partons ce soir en
voyage nous allons faire un beau voyage
très loin mais nous reviendrons but ne
soit pas trop bien sûr nous avons très
vite de retour
et si vous avez été sages nous vous
raconterons notre voyage et toutes les
belles choses que nous avons vu alors
tout est prêt nounours tout est en bonne
en de marche patron que tu as envie
d'embrasser nicolas et pimprenelle avant
de partir
et hop bon le seul homme à homme aux
bobos ne traîne pas car les vents sont
bons qu'est ce que tu as apporté dans ta
grosse patton a bouilli pour ne raconter
une histoire
non c'est un livre de géographie suis
juste venu vous embrasser avant notre
départ donc quelques minutes
nous partons pour le mexique mxic c'est
quoi c'est dû
regardez nous sommes ici oui nous allons
survoler cette groen mer pour aller là
dans ce pays qui s'appelle le mexique
faisait pas loin
ça y est nous et ce avant mexique oh non
ce n'est pas si simple baroud est longue
et difficile mais j'ai une bonne
boussole une bonne petite brise au
départ un brin de nice 3 1 c'est le vent
qui nous poussera ensuite un gentil
petit couple alizés qui un très gentil
vent traite ou moulin
pourvu que nous ne rencontrions pas les
cumulo nanami chinois
je les connais cela ils ne nous
laisseraient pas passer à
il sait comment y abat vous allez là-bas
seules celles le mexique
traversé par le tropique le mexique et
sous un climat
oh oh moi qui n'aime pas la chaleur
[Musique]
tiens mon chapeau et un jeune père simon
petit nicolas ou les lieux avec un
chapeau comme ça en zone tropicale
quelle chaleur il va faire tiens noces
c'est pour faire du vin un nouveau toy
que ses hôtes y voyons acapulco mexique
au courant roberts ororo en savane hors
jeu tapas trochain ont dû rencontre de
tout est thème maya des indiens des amis
le seul salut qu'à lycée rocha au renard
arctique ou nuage blanc et voici gaz mon
auto qui furent au qu'est ce que c'est
la fille du grand chelem woods hole
c'est l'indien ça te laisse pas dole on
parle espagnol au mexique et une
ingérence et bonne nuit au petit indien
chaussures je le redirai buenas noches
mucho dessous
alors il faut que je me sauve les
enfants à bientôt
on revoit ainsi en hausse à 10 ans
[Musique]
nicolas auneau ce match
un preneur
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
à bientôt pour nos petits et grands amis
soyez bien sage pendant notre absence
les enfants mais ma parole
c'est un mexicain laisse sonore à
travers en route fidèle compagnon les
vents sont favorables
oui on brûle en avant bonne nuit des
enfants faites de beaux rêves
à bientôt à bientôt
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]